Thanks man.
Thanks for doing this.
Thanks for coming in 100% man.
Uh,
people don't know the story.
We'll give them the brief synopsis.
I found out about your story online because there was this viral thing that was
going on about a chef who was getting protested by a bunch of animal rights
activists and Vegans who decided to camp out in front of your business and try
to the restaurant called Antler and Toronto try to,
I don't know what the fuck they were trying to do,
but you decided to butcher uh,
a leg of deer in front of them and it became this horrific thing.
Like how could you do that and a place that serves meat.
How could you prepare the meat right in front of them?
Like how did this all get started?
How did it become such a crazy viral story and why?
Why were they mad at you when there's a million other restaurants around you?
All right,
so it started in about December.
A boot include number one,
the Canadian,
the crazy Canadian.
Besides being on ice,
that's why it went viral cause I wasn't being nice.
I wasn't the stereotypical Canadian.
No.
Well you weren't even being mean.
You're just doing your job,
doing my thing.
So they started in December and they really,
this right in front of your face.
They really got pissed off with our,
we have a little chalkboard sign out front.
Um,
I'll give you the car.
We have a 45 seat restaurant,
so we're a small,
uh,
have one business partner who's a my best friend and family friend.
And um,
we had a little chalkboard sign out front that said Venison is the new Kale and
you know,
we get cute with our sign.
We,
we tease other restaurants around us like we have fun with the sign and it's
fun.
And uh,
the cyclist Vegan rode by and took huge offense to our sign and all of a sudden
one day these protesters just showed up.
So,
um,
originally I was just kind of frustrated because they're totally misguided
because,
um,
we take a lot of pride in where our food comes from.
We have Vegan and vegetarian dishes on the menu.
Uh,
and I,
I really respect that type of diet.
So we were just totally floored with why this was happening.
And,
um,
so this started going,
they'd started come every week and they went from like two or three people being
kind of peaceful to being like 10,
15 people,
not so peaceful.
So,
uh,
it's when it turned not so peaceful.
They were shouting at our,
at our guests and shouting in our door and really trying to harm our business.
That,
uh,
I just kind of got fed up.
Last resort went down,
we get a hold dear a couple of times a month and we,
we butchered ourselves and I just said,
screw it.
Screw it.
I'm like,
I'm going to get these people to get out of here.
So I thought that that would make them go away.
How did you think that was going to make them go away and not escalate it?
Uh,
I dunno,
I was,
it was just totally like last resort,
a totally fed up.
I wanted to defend myself,
defend our customers.
You know,
you could see people walking in visibly upset.
Um,
you know,
they're being shouted at being screamed at,
called a murderer as they're walking in for dinner.
Like you're going on a date,
you want to have this time and then people are screaming at you,
uh,
you know,
just for eating.
So,
uh,
I was just fed up and I just kinda thought like,
you know,
buzz off and why?
So just one sign once I sitting is the new Kale one sign set this whole thing
off.
Yeah.
And you're surrounded by restaurants.
I mean,
I know where you are.
So,
so we're surrounded by restaurants.
There's an actual butcher shop across the street and if you go in,
there's like whole cattle hanging that's okay.
And their butcher shop,
you're a problem with your comparison to Kale.
You attack their sacred Hale God,
we're promoting a meat.
I Dunno.
That's totally bizarre.
Cause you were promoting it.
We were promoting it or,
yeah.
So it just didn't promote anything and they were allowed to cycle by and dream
of Broccoli without interference.
Yeah.
Man,
I have no idea.
It's totally bizarre.
I'm sorry.
How many times did they protest you?
Um,
I think it's about eight now.
Eight.
They're coming weekly.
They still do.
There's one this Friday.
Oh,
Jesus.
So they organize,
they organize them.
There's like Facebook groups,
there's a,
they're basically giving us an ultimatum.
We have to put their slogan in our window and they'll go away.
But yeah.
What's their slogan?
Um,
there's,
there's like,
I can't remember it word for word,
but it's,
you know,
like killing animals is wrong and they have feelings while,
yeah.
Do you have to put that in your window?
We don't.
We're not going to,
there's no way.
Absolutely.
That's what they want.
Yeah.
So it's like eco terrorism,
extortion,
wherever you want to call it.
Wow.
Well,
the part,
the part of this that drives you the most crazy is the fact that you are
surrounded by restaurant.
We're surrounded by restaurants.
You're surrounded by,
like you said,
your cross street from a butcher shop,
97% of the people in the world eat meat.
It's something,
something crazy like that.
I mean,
I'm sure everyone has really been pulled.
I'm sure it's not that accurate,
but it's somewhere between 95 and 97.
It's big.
And I think we know we're an easy target.
You know,
her name is antler.
We were,
I think they're mad because,
um,
you know,
their,
their thing is that we're promoting ethical farming and their beliefs is there
is no such thing as that ethical farming that all meat is murder.
And um,
you know,
if you look up murder in the dictionary,
it has to do with humans.
You know,
it has nothing to do with animals.
And um,
there is such a thing as ethical farming and sustainable farming and we work
really hard to make sure that where we get our meat from,
his,
uh,
from the best possible place we can.
And it's local.
So it's supporting our local farmers that are,
you know,
within hours of our restaurant.
Now when you say that they started out nice,
like how many people were there in the beginning?
Two,
three,
four.
And then they weren't,
they had signs and they were just kind of,
you know,
promoting their message,
but they weren't really yelling and screaming.
And what escalated it.
Um,
so we would call the police.
We,
we kind of got wind of it on their Facebook groups,
so we would call the police and have the police there to make sure everyone's
safe.
Because one thing like customers are scared,
our staff are scared.
Like no one's dealt with this before.
I've never dealt with this before.
Um,
so we would have the police there,
you know,
they were,
the police were amazing.
Um,
and then,
you know,
one time we kind of,
okay,
let's not call the police.
Let's see what happens.
Maybe it'll just,
they'll go away.
And uh,
so then like a megaphone came out,
uh,
our neighbors were coming down and getting in fights with them and it was,
it was ugly.
So we called the police to come and choose cry.
Keep the peace.
Yeah.
A megaphone.
Part of the problem with these kinds of things is it becomes a contest.
It becomes a battle,
you know,
trying to see who's going to win.
And they're absolutely on a team.
I mean this,
that's one of the things that happens with veganism.
And I think it happens with hunters too.
Excuse me.
People become very tribal,
you know,
and you know,
it's us versus them and they want to win.
And then it becomes this thing where,
you know,
look,
the reality is a lot of people are idiots and they don't have a lot going on in
their life.
And so when something comes up where it becomes a primary focus of their life,
one restaurant is a logical as it might be that becomes a battleground.
And it's an ideological battle ground for,
you know,
don't eat meat ever versus sustainable farming.
You know this,
look,
I'm sure I know you're a hunter.
I'm sure you feel a certain amount of remorse when an animal dies 100%.
And you know,
that's a big part of sort of my beliefs in my philosophy and why I'm working on
this cookbook right now is because,
uh,
I think that,
you know,
if you do eat meat,
you should be able to kill an animal and experienced that.
And I think that if people were to actually kill an animal,
they would see,
you know,
what goes into that.
And I don't think people would consume as much mean and I don't think people
would definitely,
you know,
they certainly wouldn't waste as much meat as they do.
And it's,
it's just really upsetting and I think it's totally misguided.
You know,
why we were targeted.
Well,
I mean,
like I said,
I think it just becomes a game.
Yeah.
It becomes a,
the big tribal game,
you know,
there's,
there's a real argument are real argument that I support against factory farming
and factory farming is the way most people are getting their meat in terms of
like,
in terms of like cheeseburgers and fast food and stuff along those lines.
I mean,
you're not getting it from the most ethical sources.
It's just,
it's not financially sustainable to do it that way.
Everything would cost more money.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
that's a real problem that we as a society,
it's not obviously not you or I,
that it was set up the system,
but that this system is a system that we find ourselves a part of.
It's a real problem.
I've removed myself from it for the most part,
but occasionally I'm on the road and I'm hungry and you know,
I'll eat some meat.
That's just whatever.
Totally.
It's,
it's a necessary evil,
you know,
in sort of sorts.
It's not really necessary at all that maybe that's the wrong way to describe it,
but it's how the system's been set up and it's,
it's actually why I started hunting and doing what I do because I watched these
documentaries like food inc and these things that kind of shine a light on,
you know,
the system and how this stuff is actually being produced.
And it's horrible.
It's a,
it's terrible.
He is.
Yeah.
And I think that's the real number one problem and you know,
and this Vegan activist message to go after,
you know,
these types of farming,
we support as well and we agree with.
So the fact that we were targeted for this,
um,
was really,
really frustrating.